there was a podcast interview I was
listening to with one of the stars from
Party Down and you mentioned that were
delusional earlier and he said he looks
back on his career now and realized that
if he wasn't delusional at that point
because everyone was talking wow they're
doing so great and he was telling that
himself that same message yeah he would
have given up if he had faced the
realities of really where he was which
is if he had stopped even though he was
getting these you know under five roles
and his different things no one would
have cared so he said he almost needed
that self delusion to keep going what do
you think about that in a town that you
want to puff yourself up yeah in order
to be you know bigger is better
Hollywood doesn't always respond with
honesty yeah that I mean I think that's
a very very complex question and there
may be some semantics at play there in
terms of what we mean by delusional for
me my my use of the term delusional
within the context or nobody filmmaking
is is a very practical one
it's once again how much professional
leverage you have so that's my focus now
delusional and the more emotional sense
in the sense of self-esteem in the sense
of ability or promise in that sense sure
I think we all need a healthy dose of
that we all need to believe to a certain
degree that we can make it that we do
have enough talent that we do have
enough diligence to make it whatever
that means to me making it means I'm a
professional I'm a professional in the
film business I'm a person that a
certain number of people think my
thoughts and my product is important my
content and worth it to watch and listen
to so yeah I think on the emotional side
the delusional yeah I think we do need a
good healthy dose of that for sure but
obviously not to the degree
becomes some kind of psychological
condition at which exists as you've seen
a lot of people I mean I've been on
visit Alaska I'll say I went to I went
to a premiere my friends had their
premiere of the frit film they were all
nobodies
there were all nobody filmmakers you
know once again nobody using my term my
sense of the word they're important to
me I was there I was supporting them but
they had you know they they had like
these random people coming them
interviewing them with the cameras and
but they they brought these people there
the it's like they created this facade
and I think there's a certain point at
which when you cross this line of
delusion meant or delusional never the
word is delusion it becomes
counterproductive because now you leave
behind the what's most important the
hard work the creativity the self
creation
so if delusion gets to a point which you
believe your own self invention is gonna
carry you through well you're not doing
the work anymore and I see that a lot I
see a lot of people networking a lot
more than they're creating that's kind
of what I'm saying so yeah so yes and no
I guess to to that notion of delusion we
were talking earlier today we did a
podcast interview we're talking about
perception how there's a perception that
you know certain people even though in
the community or even in the
or in one place that things must be so
wonderful for them so what is your
perception of people that have crossed
over I mean it do you feel that it's
been just it's been a lucky break
how much work do you think it takes to
get to that other side yeah I don't
believe there is another side and I
believe in in the in any type of popular
culture which is what we do you have to
continually make it so you are
it's like Warhol's 15 minutes of fame
you I believe you could have numerous 15
minutes of fame but you need to continue
to work hard and create work reinvent
yourself do whatever it takes
be true to yourself be true your work
and continue to make it so you know you
you can make a film that makes a splash
and that'll take you it'll snowball a
little bit but that snowball is not a
self-generating snowball you have to
continually be behind it pushing it and
sometimes a big chunk falls off you make
that dud you make something that sucks
you know or you piss someone off and you
know you're back to a little teeny
snowball but once again you gotta be
behind it generating it so I personally
I'm I'm not a believer of making it I
believe I'm a believer in creating it
continually building it forever ad
infinitum till the day you die
you